moi c'est avec et ça s'est très mal
passé c'est ça s'arrête il est obsédé
par les il est obsédé par les gonzesses
enfin à l'assemblée nationale et a plus
aucune petite nana qui veut qu'il veut
s'occuper de son bureau
il suffit de voir d'ailleurs c'est le
seul qui a une secrétaire qui doit avoir
bientôt 60 ans imite obèses enfin il ya
quand même quelque chose
qu'est ce qui s'est vu comment ça s'est
passé un mois ce qui s'est passé c'est
pour mon premier livre pour lequel je
t'avais interviewait du reste erreurs
avouées
le principe c'était de leur demander la
plus grosse erreur de leur vie donc
forcément je lui ai demandé il m'a
répondu des langues de bois comme il
devait le faire
je lui ai dit bon je suis patient de
m'en servir mais dit écoutez je pars je
vous rappelle en rentrant si je pense
que j'ai autre chose à dire il m'a
rappelée en rentrant il a proposé qu'on
soit il m'a donné une adresse que je ne
connaissais pas est déjà ça m'a étonné
parce que je connais un petit peu sa vie
plus ou moins donc je sais où il habite
je sais où et sosa permanence
l'assemblée je vois un peu où s'est
situé c'était rien de tout ça je suis
arrivé devant l'adresse je me suis garé
je suis monté c'est un appartement vide
complètement vide avec un magnétoscope
une télé vision ali offense très beau il
a bon goût monsieur bangou poutres
apparentes sublime sur cour intérieure
et
et puis là il a gentiment fermé la porte
j'ai posé le magnétophone tout de suite
pour enregistrer il a voulu juste yen a
marre pour répondre parce qu'il m'a dit
je n'y arriverai pas si vous ne tenez
pas la main et puis après de la main
c'est passé au bras et c'est passé un
peu plus un donc j'ai tout de suite
c'est vrai bon je suis arrivé je suis
arrivé là-bas j'avais un col roulé noir
alors d'accord sur fait je trouve ça
fait triper l'ailé mais qu'un col roulé
noir mais faut arrêter après surtout
c'est que ça s'est très très mal fini
parce qu'on a fini par se battre ça
s'est fini très très violemment puisque
je lui ai dit clairement annoncé battu
au sol pas qu'une paire de baffes on a
donné enfin moi j'ai donné des coups de
pied il a dégrafé mon soutien gorge il
s'assied bako qui fait ça peut faire
pour toi et moi j'ai fini par partir il
m'a envoyé tout de suite un texto en dix
ans alors je vous fais peur donnez un
peu provocateur et je lui avais parlé
quand on se battait je lui avais parlé
du lui avais dit le mot viol pour lui
faire peur ça ne lui a pas fait peur
plus que ça
comme quoi apparemment il était
accoutumé et et après la parité de
m'envoyer des textos en disant toi tu
peux te mettais tout non je suis allé
très loin chez constituer le dossier je
suis allé voir un avocat très connu en
la matière qui avait déjà une pile comme
ça à son sujet et j'ai pas osé mais je
voulais pas être jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours la fille qui a eu un problème avec
avec un homme politique
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus